when you look at the history of our
species the fact that one day the world
should be so prosperous even though the
population is increasing right that is
really astonishing I am Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV and today we're talking
with Mari and 2p he's a senior policy
analyst at the Cato Institute and he's
also the editor of human progress a
website that tracks you been progress
Mari and thanks for talking to us thank
you for having me talk a little bit
about human progress
what is the quintessence of it what are
you trying to do with it well about
three years ago I read that Ridley's
rational optimist and the book really
struck me as not only a very impressive
collection of interesting statistics but
also an explanation of why the humanity
is doing as well as idiots I thought to
myself well what can we do in order to
bring it to ordinary people right oh you
and I know that things are getting
better but ordinary people don't and so
we thought why don't we create a website
which doesn't only produce or provide
human development indicators like the
World Bank tests you know the usual
suspects education child mortality
longevity that sort of thing but also
things like for example prices of food
you know how much does a pound of beef
cost you today as opposed to 30 or 40
years ago you know relating it to people
prices of airline tickets anything that
pertains to human development okay and
so the site went live last fall it's
doing well now one of the things that we
wanted to talk with you about is that
recently the Pope Pope Francis of the
Catholic Church who speaks for a billion
plus global Catholics he came out with
statements that were interesting and I
think largely because they were
erroneous and let's talk about that
first he said that things were getting
worse in many parts of the world that
like you know actual in actual absolute
terms things are getting worse and that
capitalism is one of the main culprits
in this how do you respond to the Pope's
kind of critique of CAP
well I think there are two issues here
first of all the Pope is under the
impression that the markets are free
markets an are unfettered he uses the
expression totally autonomous markets in
fact over the past 20 years so
Washington alone has produced something
like 80 thousand different regulations
regulatory burden is 1.6 trillion
dollars we don't really have free
markets as such and the situation is
even worse in in Western Europe so
that's point number one
right it's simply mistaken to think
about the world all those you do I mean
you do agree that we have generally free
market oh yeah but haven't mixed good
you know people most economists would
say ok there's a lot of trade people on
property and they're able to more or
less sell it you know sell things yeah
well I mean if the Pope wanted to
complain about something he shouldn't be
I died I think complaining about
unfettered capitalism but about the
different distortions of capital in in
current crony capitalism such as
bailouts and subsidies and permits and
licenses and so on which really benefit
special interest groups probably go
private but not really people as a whole
yeah and I mean it's one thing you know
and certainly people in a mare in the US
and Western Europe should be pushing
back against bailouts of major financial
institutions but then the cronyism in
the former Soviet Union and in Eastern
Europe and Asia and Africa this is far
more severe right that's absolutely
right I mean we are very fortunate that
we have things like the rule of law we
have independent judiciary we have
property rights we have relatively
uncorrupted police forces and in
post-communist countries what we have
seen over the last quarter of a century
really since the fall of the Berlin Wall
is that economically these countries are
doing very well but the institutions are
much more difficult to build so the hope
is obviously that as people become
richer they become more demanding of
their political rights and start
demanding also better level of
governance so yeah I mean basically what
you're saying is that the Pope has a
backwards he shouldn't be he should be
moving towards unfettered capital
and that the problem are the fetters or
the the restraints on capitalism that
allow governments and businesses to
siphon off money to preferred yes
privilege rent secret absolutely the the
research that we have looking at
economic freedom of the world report
published by the Fraser Institute in
Canada you know that's that spanning
forty some years and what we see is that
in countries with a greater level of
economic freedom the poor are richer
they own greater share of national
wealth there is less corruption and
there are greater political and civil
liberties well making countries which
have less economical well you should be
advocating he should be really
advocating in favor of more economic
freedom rather than less I cry and and
by economic freedom we're talking
basically about the ability to kind of
own property transfer it and what on and
they start a business without having to
wait for a year for somebody to stamp
your documents well this I to get to the
second point of your critique of the
Pope's comments you know in fact things
are getting better as economic freedom
advances in many places so talk a little
bit about that because the Pope is
saying no you know things are absolutely
and worse and where is the off base on
that well it's it's an astonishing thing
because of course the document the the
papal exhortation it's 40 pages long or
something like that
and it doesn't have a single reference
it doesn't have a single quotation but
the Pope says you know there's more
violence there is more poverty there's
greater inequality and there is greater
spread of disease now in fact we know
that absolute poverty is declining
throughout the world what is absolute
absolute is measured by a one dollar a
day for people 1.25 dollars per person
and we know that those numbers are
declining throughout the world and if
the current trends continue the
Brookings Institution tells us by about
2030 we shouldn't have any countries or
absolute poverty should be effectively
eliminated I mean this is stunning
because nobody really saw this coming
right nobody saw it coming and when you
look at the history of our species the
fact that one day the world should be so
prosperous
even though the population is increasing
right that is really astonishing
okay well we'll leave it there and we
can also learn from human progress the
website state Owens Institute that more
into P edits we've been talking with
Mari and 2p is a senior policy analyst
at Cato Institute in Washington DC and
the editor of human progress a website
that pulls together all kinds of
fascinating data about positive and some
negative developments happening thank
you Mario thanks for having me for a
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie